the amount of racism and this is what's
pointed out in the documentary it's just
mind-blowing it's a good reminder of the
difficulties not too long ago in our
history how shitty things were for a
young Reggie Jackson most of my friends
were white that made a problem for me
and my white friends because the parents
did not want them to associate with me
that pain is unbelievable and the worst
thing that ever happened to me when I
was a kid I was about 11 or 12 years old
and I was riding my buddy's bicycle
because it was
dusk getting dark and he said take my
bike Reggie and get it tomorrow
and I was I was riding home his stepdad
was coming up the street in a 57
Chevrolet yellow and white with a
continental kid on the back
and he saw me riding the bike and he
pointed to me to stop and pulled over
and told me to get off the bike and walk
it back to the house
he lived about two miles away from me
and I had I was halfway home it just I
never forgot that could you go home and
say to your father I just went through
something horrible or do you just
swallow it and then live with that
I remember tears coming out of my eyes
on the way home but when I got home I
wasn't crying and my dad asked if
anything happened or what went on today
would you do and I did tell him the
story
and so I can remember a hug uh from him
but but but that's all that that's all I
can I can remember those kinds of
experiences
lead you to feel the rest of your life
like you're less than
and it's a very painful thing to
confront I honestly think it made me
stronger
it made me so much more sensitive
and aware of feelings I can be in a room
with a hundred people or 50 or 300 and
feel a racist if they're on the other
side of the room
I can feel you if I don't if I should
not if I should trust you or not you
know as you speak I can feel your depth
of of you know what's down in your heart
and what's in your stomach as you as you
speak I'm aware of that
what you're saying about my
understanding or what I felt socially
but if it impacts me at all and it I'm
gonna you're right it does that drives
me so if I can help underserved
communities with my Foundation or with
my actions with my conversations as you
and I are having now
this is a powerful way to help people
through life how you're expressing what
you feel about me and how I'm responding
to it is tremendous for people
foreign